layoffs during the pandemic may have
forced many people to rely on
unemployment or maybe think of a new way
to bring in money
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to a local man who
ditched his convention background to
open a brand new business
donald brown took a hard situation and
turned it into new opportunities
he used this van to kick start his
mobile car detailing company
saying he now washes every car as if
it's his own
due to kovitt 19 donald brown was laid
off from a steady job working in the
convention industry everybody was
concerned about what we're going to do
how we're going to pay bills and stuff
as brown worked to figure out his next
steps his girlfriend gave birth to a
baby girl
jamaica named after the country he
immigrated from
20 years ago to support his growing
family
brown says he needed to get creative
i've always thought about you know maybe
i could have a business
that generates money off you know just
delivering a service after months of
saving money
brown turned his idea into a new
business jamaica's mobile car wash and
detail
although it's just a few months old
brown says he has plans to expand his
business
you always got to think out of box even
though things may be good today
you always got to think about what if
things were to
you know just stop moving the way you
you're used to it being you know
all your life brown says years of
working hard prepared him to take this
next step
now he hopes his story of perseverance
will inspire
others in the community to start their
own business and grow the las vegas
economy
never give up you know i mean just
always keep thinking stay positive
negative energy doesn't produce anything
kate houston
8 news now